This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And this is Scott McLeod. My name is Scott McLeod. I'm a cartoonist and author, and I've been making comics for a few decades now. Probably best known for non-fiction comics, especially book called Understanding Comics,
这里是 99%无形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是斯科特·麦克劳德。我叫斯科特·麦克劳德。我是一名漫画家兼作家，画漫画已经有几十年了。可能最因非虚构漫画而知名，尤其是那本叫《理解漫画》的书，
where I explain how comics work in comics form. But I've also done fiction work, and I have a lot of different interests, and I'm very easily distracted. Scott's book, Understanding Comics, which is 25 years old this year, is a seminal deconstruction of comics as an art form and mode of communication. A little cartoon Scott jumps between panels of the 215-page book, explaining how pictures and words in combination create a new language for telling stories and describing the world. The book was the culmination of a bunch of ideas that had been swirling around Scott's head for years. Everybody knew or they thought they knew what comics were and it was a very limiting
我在书中以漫画的形式解释了漫画是如何运作的。但我也创作过虚构作品，我有很多不同的兴趣，而且非常容易分心。斯科特的书《理解漫画》今年已经 25 岁了，它是将漫画作为一门艺术形式和交流媒介的开创性解构之作。一个卡通小人斯科特在 215 页的书页间跳跃，解释了图片与文字的结合如何创造了一种用于讲述故事和描述世界的新语言。这本书是斯科特多年来一直在脑海中盘旋的各种想法的结晶。每个人都知道，或者他们自以为知道什么是漫画，而那是一个非常局限的
idea. I see video games and other media dealing with the same problem today, maybe even podcasts, is that people have had this idea that comics were just four color, cheaply printed, cheaply made comics about almost all superheroes or funny animals, that they were disposable entertainment that neither the writing nor the art was anything that was going to last or be significant. And even though I saw a lot of comics that conformed to that definition, I mean there were certainly plenty of bad comics out there. To me, it was just an art form.
想法。我看到今天的电子游戏和其他媒介也在处理同样的问题，也许播客也是如此，人们过去认为漫画只是四色印刷的、廉价印制的、粗制滥造的，几乎全都是关于超级英雄或搞笑动物的漫画，它们是一次性的娱乐，无论是文字还是艺术，都不会持久或具有重要意义。尽管我见过很多符合那种定义的漫画，我的意思是，外面确实有很多糟糕的漫画。对我来说，它只是一种艺术形式。
It was an art form that was capable of so much more. And I felt like the first step was wiping the slate clean and trying to approach it from almost a clinical, value, neutral sort of standpoint where it's just like, well, what are the essential elements? And the essential elements of comics are just putting one picture after another and substituting space for time. You're just saying that as you move from one space to the next, you're moving from one moment to the next.
它是一种能够承载更多内容的艺术形式。我觉得第一步是抹去一切成见，试着从一个几乎是临床的、价值中立的角度来接近它，也就是：基本要素是什么？而漫画的基本要素就是把一张图片放在另一张图片后面，用空间代替时间。你只是在说，当你从一个空间移动到下一个空间时，你就是在从一个时刻移动到下一个时刻。
And that idea, to me, had just limitless applications, and it drew a boundary around a continent of possibilities that as far as I was concerned, we'd only just begun to explore. When you wipe this late clean and started with a new definition of comics, or at least, a refined definition of comics, can you rattle it off the top of your head what the definition was from the book? Oh, yeah. Because my mentor, Will Eisner, had used the term sequential art, and I said, you know, for the most part, most 90% of the time, you can the term sequential art night, and I said, you know, for the most part, most 90% of the time you can just say sequential art.
这个想法对我来说有无限的应用前景，它在充满无限可能的大陆周围画了一条界线，就我而言，我们才刚刚开始探索。当你抹去成见，用对漫画的新定义，或者至少是精炼的定义重新开始时，你能脱口说出书中的定义是什么吗？哦，可以。因为我的导师威尔·艾斯纳曾用过“顺序艺术”这个词，我说，你知道的，在大多数情况下，90% 的情况下，你可以直接说顺序艺术。
People get it. But then right away they'll say things like, well, what about animation? That's sequential art. So I had to come up with the longer definition that erased as many loopholes as possible. And what I came up with was juxtapose pictorial and other images and deliberate sequence, which I just, just for fun, I got I, you know, just for fun, I got to, you know, like really narrow it down. Just in case you didn't fully absorb that definition,
人们懂的。但紧接着他们就会说，比如，那动画呢？那也是顺序艺术。所以我不得不提出一个更长的定义，尽可能地消除漏洞。我想出的定义是：将 pictorial（图像）和其他图像按刻意的顺序并置，我只是——为了好玩，我——你知道的，为了好玩，我不得不，你知道的，把它真正缩小范围。以防你没有完全理解那个定义，
it's juxtapose pictorial and other images in deliberate sequence. Some people thought that, you know, we had to stop calling them comics and start calling them juxtapose pictorial in other images and deliberate sequences. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,, no. That's you just you do that once and then you go back to calling them comics. People put a lot of value on labels and and a lot of folks, you know, they get all up in arms that oh they're calling them graphic novels these days. They're putting on airs and it's like no, no, no, you can call it
那就是：将图像和其他图像按刻意的顺序并置。有些人认为，你知道，我们必须停止称它们为漫画，而开始称它们不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。那是——你只做一次，然后你又叫它们漫画了。人们对标签赋予了很高的价值，许多人，你知道的，他们会气势汹汹地反对说：哦，他们现在管这叫图像小说。他们摆谱，这就好像——不，不，不，你可以管它叫
comics if you want. I was just saying that that, know, comics, we need to allow the word to take on new meanings. And every art form has different modes of dress, right? You can read about something in film, comment, and then you can go to the Academy of Motion Pictures to see the award ceremony, and then you can go out and see a movie the next day. Now, you're using these different words as different ways of illuminating the different functions, the different styles, the different moods that come out of that art form, but it's okay. You can still call the movies, you can still call them comics. What term do you like? I like comics because actually I think it's fairly dry. I think that it's been a long time
漫画，如果你想的话。我只是在说，漫画，我们需要允许这个词获得新的含义。每种艺术形式都有不同的着装方式，对吧？你可以读到关于电影评论的东西，然后你可以去电影艺术与科学学院看颁奖典礼，然后你第二天可以去看电影。现在，你使用这些不同的词作为不同的方式来阐明这种艺术形式所产生的不同功能、不同风格、不同情绪，但这没关系。你仍然可以称它们为电影，你仍然可以称它们为漫画。你喜欢什么术语？我喜欢漫画，因为实际上我觉得它相当枯燥。我觉得人们认为所有漫画都必须搞笑已经是很久以前的事了。
since people thought that all comics had to be funny. When I was growing up, everybody assumed that all comics were muscle bound guys and skin tight suits beaten the crap out of each other. So we had already lost the original meaning, and that rendered it just this dry little bundle of sticks, this little collection of phonemes that you could pretty much stuff any meaning into. And also it's quick, it's short, two syllables. So if I were to pick up a comic book or, you know, turn to the comic section of the newspaper, are there certain things that you could teach me, like how to decode comics in a certain
我成长的时候，每个人都理所当然地认为所有漫画都是肌肉男穿着紧身衣在互殴。所以我们已经失去了最初的意义，这使得它变成了这样一个枯燥的小束棍棒，这样一个你可以塞进几乎任何含义的小语素集合。而且它很简短，很短，两个音节。所以，如果我要拿起一本漫画书，或者，你知道的，翻到报纸的漫画版，有没有什么特定的东西你可以教我，比如如何以某种
way that, like, you could tell me like, well, the artist is trying to do this when they do this. What are little take home facts about decoding comic? Well, the first thing are the universals that is if you're looking at a comic strip or comic book or graphic novel, there are a few things everybody has to do. Whether they want to or not, these are the obligatory decisions that they all make.
方式来解码漫画，比如你可以告诉我，艺术家在做这个时是想达到这个目的。关于解码漫画，有哪些可以带回家的实用知识呢？嗯，第一件事就是普遍规律，也就是说，如果你在看连环画、漫画书或图像小说，有一些东西是每个人都必须要做的。不管他们愿意与否，这些都是他们所有人都要做出的强制性决定。
And one of the first decisions they make is choosing their moments. No matter what, you're breaking the world into moments. And it's a non-trivial problem. It's an engineer would say, I'm a son of an engineer. And because if you think about it, any kind of narrative that you want to tell can be broken down in an infinite number of ways. You know, I could do a 10,000 panel graphic novel of me taking a spoonful of cereal from a bowl, right?
他们做出的首要决定之一就是选择他们的时刻。无论如何，你都在将世界分解为一个个时刻。这不是一个微不足道的问题。一个工程师会说，我是个工程师的儿子。因为如果你仔细想想，你想讲述的任何叙事都可以用无限多种方式来分解。你知道的，我可以做一个一万格的图像小说，内容是我从碗里舀一勺麦片，对吧？
And just lifting up to my mouth. If you want, I could just break it down by microseconds, by nanoseconds. Or I could do you a two panel sequence of the entire history of the universe, right? Big bangs, heat death, you're done. So that means that you can slice it up anyway you like. And yet if I asked you, hey, what did you do yesterday? There's a part of your mind that immediately leverages this tremendous neural horsepower to deciding what matters. You know, we have these wonderful saliency filters
然后把它举到嘴边。如果你愿意，我可以按微秒、纳秒来分解它。或者我可以为你做一个两格的序列，讲述整个宇宙的历史，对吧？大爆炸，热寂，结束了。这意味着你可以随心所欲地切割它。然而，如果我问你：嘿，你昨天干嘛了？你的大脑里有一部分会立即利用这种巨大的神经处理能力来决定什么才是重要的。你知道，我们有这些奇妙的显着性过滤器，
that choose the moments quite naturally. and most cartoonists choose them pretty naturally. They know once they have a story to tell, they know what moments matter. But they have to make that decision, even if they're not making it consciously. And then from that point, you have to choose the the angles, the framing. How close are you going to get to that thing you want to show? How far away are you going to be? What angle is it going to be? Worms Eye View, Eagles View, are you going to have to establish the scene by pulling it way back?
它们相当自然地选择那些时刻。大多数漫画家也相当自然地选择它们。一旦他们有了要讲的故事，他们就知道哪些时刻是重要的。但他们必须做出这个决定，即使他们不是有意识地在做。然后从那个角度出发，你必须选择角度、取景。你打算离你要展示的东西有多近？你打算离得多远？会是什么角度？仰视、鸟瞰，你是不是需要把画面拉得很远来交代场景？
And then all those decisions about how you draw the things. How do you draw it so it's recognizable? How do you draw it so it's expressive? How do you draw it so that it's visually interesting? How do you balance out dynamics versus clarity? All of these things? And then, of course, the mixture of words and pictures and the way it flows. And it's an endless series of decisions. But these are decisions we all make, whether we do them
然后是所有关于如何绘制这些东西的决定。你怎么画才能让人认出来？你怎么画才能表现力十足？你怎么画才能让它在视觉上有趣？如何在动态和清晰度之间取得平衡？所有这些？然后，当然，文字和图片的结合以及它的流动方式。这是一个无休止的决定系列。但这些都是我们所有人都会做出的决定，无论我们是否
consciously or not. So, every medium has its strengths and weaknesses. And in your mind, what are the best kind of ideas that comics are best at conveying? And maybe what are some of the ideas that are hardest to convey in comics. When it comes to visual explanations, I found that comics are really good at the intro level. When you're getting down to a really granular level, like for instance, if you wanted to use comics to explain the latest congressional budget bill or something like that, that can be a problem because they're time intensive.
有意识地去做。所以，每种媒介都有它的长处和短处。在你的心目中，漫画最擅长传达什么样的想法？也许有哪些想法是漫画最难传达的？说到视觉解释，我发现漫画非常擅长入门级别的题材。当你深入到非常细颗粒度的层面时，比如说，如果你想用漫画来解释最新的国会预算案之类的事情，那可能会是个问题，因为它们很耗时。
It takes a long time to put them together, and something like that. That can be a problem because they're time intensive. It takes a long time to Put them together and something like that is better in text But if you wanted to explain you know particle physics or Some you know engineering principle or something like that something that's gonna stick around It's a wonderful entry to almost any subject and I've done a bunch of things like that. I recently did a comic explaining Kubernetes, which is, this was for Google. It's a way of orchestrating containerized applications. If that's something you're planning to do tomorrow, there's a comic that'll explain how to do that. But what I'm able to do is I'm able to lay out the map. I'm able to give you a sense that, yeah, this is what the neighbor looks like. This is how everything is interrelated. This is the shape of the subject. Comics are
把它们拼凑起来需要很长时间，诸如此类的事情。这可能会是个问题，因为它们很耗时。把它们拼凑起来需要很长时间，而类似的事情用文字来表达会更好。但如果你想解释，你知道的，粒子物理学或某个，你知道的，工程学原理之类的事情，一些能够长久流传的东西，它是进入几乎任何学科的绝妙切入点，我做过很多这样的事情。我最近画了一本解释 Kubernetes 的漫画，这是为谷歌做的。这是一种编配容器化应用的方法。如果你打算明天做这件事，有一本漫画会向你解释怎么做。但我能够做到的是，我能够勾勒出地图。我能够让你感觉到，是的，这就是邻里的样子。这就是一切相互关联的方式。这就是主题的形态。漫画非常
really good at that. But the flip side of what comics are good at, it's tricky because I'm always reluctant to say that the medium is inherently good at something because that immediately beggars the question as you've already asked me What's it maybe not so good at? And the thing is whenever I think comics are not capable of something Somebody always proves me wrong. What's an example of that? Well like hard math, you know, some people have actually given it a run it like where they're using comics to explain Mathematical concept something that I thought would probably just be a non-starter.
擅长这一点。但漫画所擅长的反面，就很棘手了，因为我总是很不情愿地说某种媒介天生擅长什么，因为这马上就会引出你刚才已经问过我的问题：它可能不擅长什么？问题是，每当我以为漫画做不到某事时，总有人证明我是错的。这有什么例子吗？嗯，比如高等数学，你知道的，有些人真的尝试过，他们用漫画来解释数学概念，这曾被我认为是根本行不通的。
And it turns out, no, actually, you can give that a try. And of course, when I began, it was all superheroes, it was all spectacle, it was all sensationalism. And there were many people who felt the comics were inherently good at that. But pretty soon into my career, even before I became my career formally, I discovered Japanese comics and they were doing comics about everything. They were fishing comics, they were majong comics, they were comics about romance, they're
结果证明，不，实际上，你可以尝试一下。当然，当我刚开始的时候，全都是超级英雄，全都是奇观，全都是哗众取宠。有许多人觉得漫画天生就擅长这些。但在我的职业生涯刚开始不久，甚至在我正式以其为职业之前，我就发现了日本漫画，它们画的是关于一切的漫画。有钓鱼漫画，有麻将漫画，有关于浪漫的漫画，
comics about ninjas. It didn't matter, they could be about anything. But if you grew up in America, you might mistakenly think that the medium was somehow built, somehow inherently constructed in such a way that the love affair between comics and superiors were somehow inevitable. Just like in 1962, somebody could think that the love affair between movies and big spectacular musicals was inevitable. It wasn't there.
有关于忍者的漫画。无所谓，它们可以关于任何事。但如果你是在美国长大的，你可能会误以为这种媒介不知何故就是为了那种东西而生的，不知何故天生就是以某种方式构建的，以至于漫画和超级英雄之间的爱恋在某种程度上是不可避免的。就像在 1962 年，可能会有人认为电影和宏大华丽的音乐剧之间的爱恋是不可避免的一样。其实并没有。
There was nothing that said that movies had to go in that direction. It's just that's just the call to sack that they wound up with. What I love to look at when it comes to sort of everyday objects that people are very familiar with is I like to look at them and sort of recognize that they represent choices. And maybe they were choices so long ago that we forget that they're even choices. So, for example, I was thinking about the speech bubble in a comic book and realizing how ob that is if you really think about it. And are there things like that that are these little revolutionary visual representations of things that you could sort of walk us through.
没有任何东西规定电影必须朝着那个方向发展。那只是它们最终落入的死胡同。当我看到人们非常熟悉的一些日常物品时，我喜欢看它们并某种程度上意识到它们代表了选择。也许这些选择是如此久远以至于我们甚至忘记了它们是选择。所以，比如，我想到了漫画书里的对话气泡，并且意识到如果你认真想想，那是多么离奇的一件事。有没有类似这样的小型革命性视觉表现形式的东西，你可以带我们回顾一下。
Maybe who did them, when did this change? When did it go from being in the box to being in the bubble, you know, like words, anything about the evolution of comics that represent these revolutionary little punctuated equilibrium but are so built into the way we perceive the world that we don't even recognize them as choices. Well, I'm going to pull a 180 here and say that actually this is a good example of something that maybe is intrinsic to the medium is kind of inevitable. When you do stumble on one of those, usually the first evidence is that it happened early. And speech bubbles happen as early as certain
也许是谁创造了它们，这种改变是什么时候发生的？是什么时候从方框里变成对话气泡里的，你知道的，比如文字，关于漫画演变的任何代表了这些革命性的、小规模的间断平衡，但又如此深入到我们感知世界的方式中，以至于我们甚至不认为它们是选择的东西？嗯，我要来个 180 度大转弯，说实际上这是一个很好的例子，说明某些东西可能是该媒介固有的，可以说是不可避免的。当你偶然发现其中一个时，通常第一个证据就是它发生得很早。而对话气泡早在某些
European broadsheets. And they are speech bubbles. There's no question about it. You know, I could show you something from 1600, 1500, where they're in the shape of scrolls, but they are dialogue coming out of people's mouths. So as soon as you start squaring off things into panel borders, which they were also doing in those days, those rectangular panel borders, yeah, you start to have that, you start to have speech bubbles.
欧洲单页印刷品中就出现了。而且它们就是对话气泡。毫无疑问。你知道的，我可以向你展示一些 1600 年、1500 年的东西，它们的形状像卷轴，但它们是从人们嘴里出来的对话。所以一旦你开始用格子边框把东西方框化——他们在那个年代也这么做，那些矩形格子边框——是的，你开始有了这个，你开始有了对话气泡。
You can even see sort of equivalent things in things like pre-Columbian picture manuscripts and some of the stuff. I think there's some dialogue in the Bayou tapestry. So yeah, this was gonna happen, no matter what, because dialogue, speech, it's part of life and anything that purports to represent life in any kind of artistic narrative medium,
你甚至可以在前哥伦布时期的图画手稿和一些东西中看到类似的东西。我想巴约挂毯里也有一些对话。所以是的，这无论如何都会发生，因为对话、言语，它是生活的一部分，任何声称要在某种艺术叙事媒介中表现生活的艺术，
it's gonna have to account for that in some way, shape, or form. That said, I think it's what, it is kind of what Willisner called a desperation device in the sense that because we have a soundless medium for most of our history, we were kind of stuck. And it does feel a little bit like a hack. I think there's a little part of every cartoonist's heart sinks a little that we have to use this shape.
都必须以某种形状或形式来解释这一点。话虽如此，我认为这有点像是威尔·艾斯纳所说的“绝望装置”，因为在我们的历史大部时间里，我们拥有的是一个没有声音的媒介，我们有点被卡住了。而且它确实感觉有点像个权宜之计。我觉得每个漫画家心里都有一个小角落，当不得不使用这种形状时，都会感到有些失落。
It's kind of like voiceover in movies. Yeah. Yeah, it feels like a cheat. You should be able to show it and not tell it. It does. It feels like a cheat. And I think that's why I think when comics are silent when you have these silent sequences, some cartoonists do nothing but silent comics, but most of us will do them occasionally. It feels more like pure comics.
这有点像电影里的画外音。对。对，感觉像是个作弊。你应该能够展示出来而不是说出来。确实。感觉像是个作弊。而且我想这就是为什么当漫画没有声音时——当你拥有这些无声序列时，有些漫画家只画无声漫画，但我们大多数人偶尔也会这么做。它感觉更像是纯粹的漫画。
There's that little purist gene in each of us that revels a little when we can dispense with the word. Not good news for writers. I love this term silent comics. Yeah, it's so strangely absurd, but I totally make sense that it's strange that you have this uni-media presentation that still feels so multimedia that we think of it as having sound and time and a depth to it. Exactly.
我们每个人体内都有那种小小的纯粹主义基因，当我们可以省去文字时，会感到一丝狂喜。这对作家来说可不是好消息。我喜欢“无声漫画”这个词。是的，它太奇怪、太荒谬了，但我完全理解，拥有这种单一媒介的呈现却依然让人感觉如此多媒体，以至于我们觉得它有声音、有时间和深度，这本身就很奇怪。没错。
It's very easy to forget that comics is relegated to just one of the five senses. Traditionally, of course, that's beginning to change a little bit with various mutations online and whatnot. But yeah, it's strange because it really doesn't feel that way. It does feel multimedia. And of course, that's partially because many feel that it's this acclimation of words and pictures. Even though that tends to be true, I don't think of that as the essential character of comics. I just think of that as one of comics options, but you can get some other comics scholar in here to argue with me there.
人们很容易忘记漫画仅仅从属于五种感官中的一种。传统上，随着网上各种变体等等的出现，这种情况当然开始发生了一些变化。但是的，这很奇怪，因为它的确不给人那种感觉。它确实感觉像是多媒体的。当然，部分原因是因为许多人觉得它是文字和图片的这种融合。尽管这往往是真的，但我不认为这是漫画的本质特征。我只认为那是漫画的选项之一，不过你可以找其他漫画学者来这里跟我争论。
But yeah, the evolution of those symbols though, I mean, word bloons are certainly the most visible, but the other ones, I do find very interesting, I talk in understanding comics about things like sweat beads and how you can see the evolution of written language even in the pictorial symbols. And the fact that a sweat bead is a pictorial symbol that gradually drifted so that rather than a little sweat bead on cheek, you would see a sweat bead drawn beside a face, so that it began to emanate from the face to the extent that it became a symbol that simply indicated the interstate. And now you can find manga where robots will have sweat beads on them. And it's simply a signifier of emotion. And in a lot of ways, that drift is the exact same drift you had in many pictorial-based written languages, especially in the Far East, where something would begin as simply a drawing of a chair
但是，是的，这些符号的演变，我的意思是，文字气泡当然是最显眼的，但其他的，我确实觉得非常有趣。我在《理解漫画》中谈到了诸如汗珠之类的东西，以及你如何甚至能在图画符号中看到书面语言的演变。事实上，汗珠是一个图画符号，它逐渐漂移，使得与其说是在脸颊上画一个小汗珠，不如说你会看到一张脸旁边画着一颗汗珠，以至于它开始从脸部散发出来，最终变成了一个仅仅用来表示内心状态的符号。现在你可以在漫画中发现机器人身上也有汗珠。这仅仅是情绪的标志。在很多方面，这种漂移与许多基于图画的书面语言中的漂移完全相同，尤其是在远东地区，某种东西最初可能只是一把椅子
or a drawing of a horse, and that over decades or even centuries of writing, they would become more and more abstract. That's exactly what's happening in comics. So if you were to give a 25-year post-understanding syllabus to the listeners of 99PI. What are the essential comics, maybe, you know, that show a change in form or something, and kind of like what they are, and just a little description of like, what is this doing that is particularly remarkable to you?
或一匹马的画，经过几十甚至几百年的书写，它们变得越来越抽象。这正是漫画中正在发生的事情。因此，如果要为 99PI 的听众提供一份出版 25 年后的理解漫画书单。有哪些必备的漫画，也许你知道的，能够展示形式的变化或其他什么的，大概说说它们是什么，并对以下问题做一点简短的描述：这本漫画做了什么对你而言特别非凡的事情？
If I just had a few, I would probably start with Chris Ware's building stories, which is a giant box, like a Milton Bradley game box, which has comics in a million different shapes, because that definitely sets the mind going. I would throw in a couple of crazy web comics where you can go in any direction. I would have at least one silent comic from Jim Woodring. I would include Persepolis because I think Persepolis really was a tuning fork for a lot that came after. In what way? What do you mean a tuning? Well, in terms of voices, one of the beautiful things about comics is the way that comics can offer you a very intimate and
如果只能挑几本，我可能会从克里斯·韦尔（Chris Ware）的《构建故事》（Building Stories）开始，它是一个巨大的盒子，就像一个米尔顿·布拉德利（Milton Bradley）的游戏盒，里面有成百万种不同形状的漫画，因为这绝对能让人大开脑洞。我会加入几部疯狂的网络漫画，你可以朝任何方向阅读。我会至少包含一部来自吉姆·伍德林（Jim Woodring）的无声漫画。我会把《我在伊朗长大》（Persepolis）包含进去，因为我认为它确实为后来的很多作品定下了基调。在什么方面？你说的定下基调是什么意思？嗯，就声音而言，漫画的美妙之处在于，它可以为你提供一个非常亲密且
credible voice from somebody who could just be making it up, but you know that they're not. This is something that comics journalist Joe Sacco took advantage of. He would do things like spend months or even years in a place like Palestine or the Balkans. And he would talk to people, interview them, and then he would do these painstaking drawings of the area. And you realize as journalism, you could doubt everything he's telling you, but you don't. You know that a human hand took the time to make this, and with that labor-intensive devotion came truth.
可信的声音，这个声音可能来自一个只是在瞎编的人，但你知道他没有。这是漫画记者乔·萨科（Joe Sacco）充分利用的一点。他会做这样的事：在巴勒斯坦或巴尔干半岛这样的地方花上几个月甚至几年的时间。他会与人们交谈、采访他们，然后他会 painstakingly（煞费苦心地）画出该地区的画作。作为新闻，你可能会怀疑他告诉你的所有事情，但你不会。你知道，有一只人类的手花了时间去创作这个，而伴随着这种劳动力密集的奉献而来的是真相。
There's something very convincing about it. Even though technically, it's a lot easier to fake something in a drawing than in a photograph, you know that it's true. And that was true of Persepolis too, is that Marjan Sotropi's experiences in Iran during the revolution in the war with Iraq and coming to Europe and all of these things, they just feel so credible, so personal, and they open a door to another experience. And movies can do that, books can do that, but the contact with the paper, the notion that a human hand drew this, it makes it more intimate, it makes it that their entire world is seen through their lines, and that's really exciting.
有些东西非常有说服力。尽管从技术上讲，在画画中伪造某东西比在照片中要容易得多，但你知道它是真的。这对于《我在伊朗长大》来说也是一样的，玛jane·萨塔皮（Marjane Satrapi）在革命期间、与伊拉克战争期间在伊朗的经历，以及来到欧洲的经历，所有这些都让人感觉如此可信、如此个人化，它们打开了一扇通往另一种体验的门。电影可以做到这一点，书籍可以做到这一点，但与纸张的接触、人类的手画了这个的概念，让它变得更亲密，让他们的整个世界都通过他们的线条被看到，这真的令人兴奋。
Anything else in the syllabus that we could just throw in there? Oh, the arrival by Sean Tan, a wonderful book. It looks sort of like a kid's story book, sort of like a Chris Von Alzberg, beautifully illustrated silent story, which is a kind of surrealistic meditation on what it's like to be an immigrant in a strange new place. Sean Tan moved from, I believe it was Malaysia to be an immigrant in a strange new place. Shantan moved from, I believe it was Malaysia to Australia when he was just a kid and he, and he really makes you understand what it is to go to such a new and alien place.
书单里还有什么我们可以塞进去的吗？哦，肖恩·谭（Shaan Tan）的《抵岸》（The Arrival），一本绝妙的书。它看起来有点像一本儿童故事书，有点像克里斯·冯·奥尔斯堡（Chris Van Allsburg）的作品，是一部插图精美的无声故事，是对作为一个陌生新地方的移民是何种感受的一种超现实主义沉思。肖恩·谭从，我相信是马来西亚搬到作为一个陌生新地方的移民。肖恩·谭从，我相信是马来西亚搬到了澳大利亚，当时他还是个孩子，他，他真的让你明白了去这样一个崭新而陌生的远方是怎样的体验。
He does it beautifully. But also, it's really terrific to approach comics without words. To pick something without words for your first encounter because then you have to recognize the degree to which pictures are text. Pictures are meaning, they're not just illustrations, the pictures do the talking. And, you know, it's still in popular culture
他做得非常漂亮。而且，不带文字地去接触漫画也是非常了不起的体验。为你的初次接触选择一些没有文字的东西，因为那样你就必须认识到图片在多大程度上就是文本。图片就是意义，它们不仅仅是插图，图片在进行诉说。而且，你知道，由于所有的，你知道的，漫威电影等等，超级英雄在流行文化中依然
because of all the, you know, Marvel movies and such, that the superhero is a dominant form in comics. Is there something that you find that you enjoy in them? Like, is it something that's lost to you at this point? What is your feeling about them right now? I've lost some of the joy that I had when I was first reading superhero comics, but I like the medium.
是漫画中的主导形式。有什么是你在其中发现自己所享受的吗？比如说，这是你现在已经失去的乐趣吗？你现在对它们有什么感觉？我已经失去了一些刚开始读超级英雄漫画时的那种快乐，但我喜欢这种媒介。
I think the medium has an important part to play in comics culture, but still I'm kind of happy that we're becoming a little bit more like Japan. We're starting to see more genres come in. One of the big revolutions now is in kids comics. In fact, the best-selling cartoonist in America now is Raina Telgomire, who does comics for kids. And those comics don't have any superheroes in them. Her biggest one was Smile, which was just about when she was a kid and she lost her two of her front teeth and that reconstructive surgery. It's all it is.
我认为这种媒介在漫画文化中扮演着重要的角色，不过我还是有点高兴我们正在变得越来越像日本。我们开始看到更多不同的流派涌现。现在的一大革命是儿童漫画。事实上，美国现在最畅销的漫画家是雷娜·泰尔格迈尔（Raina Telgemeier），她专门为儿童创作漫画。而那些漫画里没有任何超级英雄。她最畅销的作品是《微笑》（Smile），讲的就是她小时候门牙摔断了以及做正畸手术的事。就这么简单。
But it's just fantastic stuff. You know, we're seeing much more diversity. I just got a wonderful crowd-funded book called Bingo Love, which is just about two women of color who fall in love as kids. You know, in a Bingo parlor, and both of their families just don't approve, and they don't really get together until they're old. It's a far cry from the amazing Spider-Man. But some of the things we love the most about Spider-Man, I gotta say, were just the small moments, the everyday moments, the real moments. So there was maybe there was a seed of that even in those days. I know you're interested in graphic communication in the world at large beyond comics, but how did understanding comics and all the thoughts you put into this as a study change the way you decode
但内容棒极了。你知道，我们看到了更多的多样性。我刚刚拿到一本通过众筹出版的绝妙书籍叫《宾果之爱》（Bingo Love），讲的是两个有色人种女性在还是孩子时坠入爱河的故事。你知道，在一个宾果游乐厅里，双方家庭都不认可，直到她们老了才真正在一起。这与《惊奇蜘蛛侠》相去甚远。但我们对蜘蛛侠最热爱的某些东西，我必须说，恰恰是那些小时刻、日常时刻、真实的时刻。所以也许在那时就已经埋下了那种种子。我知道你对超越漫画的广阔世界中的图形传达很感兴趣，但是《理解漫画》以及你对作为研究投入其中的所有思考，是如何改变你解码
graphics in the world at large. Like what is something that you could point to as an example of that ties to this medium that you could help people like decode as they're walking to a city? Well, let's look at fire safety signs. Okay. Oh my God. This drives me crazy. There's a really classic little messed up fire safety graphic. You'll see it all around the country, often on the inside of hotel room doors, which is it's got two different little flames.
广阔世界中的图形的方式的？比如，有什么你可以指出作为例子、与这种媒介相关联的东西，可以帮助人们在漫步城市时进行解码的吗？好吧，让我们来看看消防安全标志。好的。哦，天哪。这快把我逼疯了。有一个非常经典、有点搞砸了的消防安全图形。你全国各地都能看到，经常在酒店房间门的内侧，它画了两个不同的小火焰。
It's got this little tiny elevator and then it's got this very big guy who's going right to left down the stairs towards the flame and about to trip over the elevator. So all they did was they found the symbols and they filled the available space with the symbols. It didn't even occur to them that the way the guy was facing or the relative size of the guy in the flames, the guys much bigger than the flames. The flames don't look particularly threatening. And why are there two of them? All of these things, they didn't consider it at all because they weren't thinking that
它画了一个很小很小的电梯，然后画了一个非常大的家伙，正从右到左走下楼梯冲向火焰，并且差一点被电梯绊倒。所以他们所做的，就是找到这些符号，然后用这些符号填满可用的空间。他们甚至没有想到这个家伙面向的方向，或者这个家伙与火焰的相对大小——这个家伙比火焰大得多。火焰看起来并不是特别具有威胁性。而且为什么有两个？所有这些事情，他们根本没有考虑，因为他们没有考虑到
maybe every visual decision has consequence, every visual decision has collateral meaning. And so I started remixing these things and turning the guy around and changing the size relationships and changing the proximity and making sure that each individual element had its own space to breathe. And I was able to come up with like three different alternatives that I think work better, that I'll probably go on a crusade to fire departments around the country.
也许每一个视觉决定都有后果，每一个视觉决定都有附带的含义。于是我开始重新混音这些东西，把这个家伙转过方向，改变大小比例，改变距离，确保每个独立的元素都有它自己的空间来呼吸。我能够想出大概三种我觉得效果更好的替代方案，我大概会为此在全国各地的消防部门发起一场十字军东征。
But now I see these things everywhere. I mean, maps, for example, 90 degree rotation is hard. Mental 90 degree rotation is very hard. And it actually upsets me when I see floor plans telling you how to get out of your burning building. And they're rotated. They're not in the same orientation as the way that you're standing because they have one map orientation for the whole building. It's the only map they print, right? But you know, your building is on fire. You're going to die any minute now, and you've got to stand there and kind of just sort
但我现在到处都能看到这些东西。我的意思是，地图，举个例子，90度旋转很难。脑海中的 90 度旋转非常难。每当我看到楼梯疏散平面图告诉你如何逃离着火的建筑时，我其实都会感到沮丧。它们是旋转的。它们的朝向跟你站立的方向不一致，因为它们对整栋建筑只有一种地图朝向。那是它们打印的唯一地图，对吧？但是你知道，你的大楼着火了。你随时都可能会死，而你不得不站在那里，然后有点像
of imagine if you were facing the other way and you return this way and wait, which always is that? And they're these two. And no, it should be clear as day. Here's the thing. I think that good visual communication should speak and be silent. What I mean by that is that that there are many kinds of visual communication that they're clear enough, you can figure it out, that is you can piece it together, but they still kind
想象一下，如果你面向另一个方向，然后你转这边，等等，到底是哪个方向？而它们有这两个方向。不，这应该一清二楚。事情是这样的。我认为良好的视觉传播应该会说话且保持沉默。我的意思是，有许多种类的视觉传播，它们足够清晰，你能搞清楚，也就是说你可以把它拼凑起来，但它们在走开时仍然会
of mumble as they walk away. Like the bike path sign, you know, it's all it is, the bike path signs, they're everywhere, right? It's just a picture of a bicycle. And then the word bike and path underneath the bicycle. And oftentimes the word bike and path are separated. And there's more space between bike and path than there is between the words bike and path and the wheels of the bicycle. Nobody will be confused by this. Everyone on earth knows that if they can read English,
喃喃自语。就像自行车道标志，你知道的，到处都是，对吧？它只是画了一辆自行车。然后在自行车下方写着“自行车”和“道路”这两个词。而且通常“自行车”和“道路”这两个词是分开的。“自行车”和“道路”之间的距离，比“自行车”和“道路”这两个词与自行车车轮之间的距离还要大。没有人会对此感到困惑。地球上的每个人都知道，如果他们能认出英文，
they know that says bike path, they know what it means. But I say it's still a pox on every damn one of them because what it does is it violates the rules of proximity so that it's like, but the words bike and path are married. There are a couple and there is infidelity going on there because they're flirting with the wheels, right? And they're creating this visual grouping of wheel and and word that's completely irrelevant to the message. Nobody will be confused by this. Ivy, my wife just tells me, let it go, let it go. It's fine. They needed room for the little bolt to go in. That's all it is. They were just making room for the bolt, Scott. to go in. That's all it is. They were just making room for the bolt, Scott. Just let it go. But, but I am telling you, instead of just saying bike path like it was supposed to, it's saying bike path, and you're like, wait, what did you say? And I said bike path. It's like, no, no,
他们就知道上面写着“自行车道”，他们知道这意味着什么。但我还是要说，这对它们每一个来说都是个祸害，因为它违反了邻近原则，以至于感觉就像是：但是“自行车”和“道路”这两个词是结婚的。它们是一对，而那里发生了不忠，因为它们在和车轮调情，对吧？它们创造了一个与信息完全无关的车轮与文字的视觉群组。没有人会对此感到困惑。伊维，我妻子总是告诉我，算了吧，算了吧。没关系。它们需要留出空间让小螺栓穿过去。事情就是这样。它们只是在为螺栓留出空间，斯科特。穿过去。事情就是这样。它们只是在为螺栓留出空间，斯科特。算了吧。但是，但是我要告诉你，它本该说“自行车道”，但它没有，它说的是“自行车道”，然后你会想：等等，你刚才说什么？我说“自行车道”。这就好像，不，不，
no, after bike path, what did you say? I didn't say anything. I just said bike path. There. You did it again. You said, what the hell was? I didn't say anything. I just said bike path. MMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM where you feel like there has to be a type of precision in the presentation of the narrative, or do you allow for a little bit more mumbling? That's a good question, because I think in comics, people embrace the mumbling. People embrace the imperfections in the cartoonist's line. They actually fall in love with the things that make a cartoonist a little clumsy, a little crowded, a little strange,
不，在“自行车道”之后，你说了什么？我什么也没说。我只说了“自行车道”。瞧。你又来了。你说了，刚才那到底是什么？我什么也没说。我只说了“自行车道”。你觉得在叙事的呈现中必须有一种精确度，还是允许稍微有些喃喃自语？这是个好问题，因为我认为在漫画中，人们包容这种喃喃自语。人们包容漫画家线条中的不完美。他们实际上爱上了那些让漫画家显得有点笨拙、有点拥挤、有点奇怪的特质，
because those are the things that only they do. And there are certainly there are craftsmen and comics who know just how to make it sing and compose it with great precision and orchestrate the line so that there is no mumbling so that there is no noise. And I love them too, but the imperfections I think are part of what people are drawn to in my medium. It is an imperfect medium because it is the creation of an imperfect species. And the idiosyncrasies of cartoonists like, you know, say Robert Crom or Charles Schultz, these are the things that I dissecting the world of visual communication relate to close family members who are blind?
因为那些是只有他们才能做到的事情。当然，漫画界也有一些工匠，他们知道如何让画面歌唱，以极高的精确度进行构图，并编排线条，使得没有喃喃自语，没有杂音。我也很喜欢他们，但这些不完美我认为正是人们被我的媒介所吸引的部分原因。它是一种不完美的媒介，因为它是某个不完美的物种所创造的。而漫画家们的特质，比如，罗伯特·克鲁姆（Robert Crumb）或查尔斯·舒尔茨（Charles Schulz），这些我在解剖视觉传达世界时，与那些失明的近亲家属有何关联？
I ask that question and get a really cool answer from Scott McLeod right after this. You really take in the world with a lot of attention to the visual cues and graphic interface, and you happen to have a blind father, you have a blind daughter. How has that affected the way you perceive the world and even like how you relate to them? The condition that both my father who's been deceased for some time and my daughter have is called Stargart's disease. It's an inherited condition and it's a form of macular degeneration. Their central vision is what wasn't as affected.
我问了这个问题，并从斯科特·麦克劳德那里得到了一个非常酷的回答，广告之后马上揭晓。你吸收世界时对视觉线索和图形界面给予了极大的关注，而你恰好有一个失明的父亲，你还有一个失明的女儿。这如何影响了你感知世界的方式，甚至你是如何与他们相处的？我那去世一段时间的父亲和我女儿得的这种病叫做斯塔加特病（Stargart's disease）。这是一种遗传性疾病，是黄斑变性的一种形式。他们的中心视力受到的影响较小。
My daughter being 24, living in Portland, wearing Doc Martin boots and listening to aeroplane over the sea on vinyl, is more than happy to tell me the ways in which I'm ableist and the different problems in my focus on visual communication because there are people for whom visual communication has some pretty severe limits. And we've had some wonderful discussions about accessibility. Just very recently, actually, a bit of epiphany when I was talking to her about this, her name is Sky, and Sky and I were talking about accessibility, and I had been complaining,
我女儿今年 24 岁，住在波特兰，穿着马丁靴，听着黑胶唱片里的《Aeroplane Over the Sea》，她非常乐意指出我在多大程度上表现出了“健全主义者”的倾向，以及我过分关注视觉传达所带来的各种问题，因为对于某些人来说，视觉传达有着相当严格的局限性。我们关于无障碍性进行过非常精彩的讨论。就在最近，实际上，当我跟她谈起这件事时，我灵光一闪。她叫斯凯（Sky），斯凯和我谈到了无障碍性，而我一直在抱怨，
I had been, you know, bitching about some bit of bad design that affects me, and I realized that we were talking about the same thing. The idea that there is, it is a human we were talking about the same thing. The idea that there is, it is a human right, information is a human right, and between the information and the person who can use that information. I think we're talking about fire maps, actually, and the recent fires here in Southern California, and the limitations of the different displays that went out,
我一直在抱怨某个影响我的糟糕设计，然后我意识到我们谈论的是同一件事。这个想法是，这是一个人类——我们谈论的是同一件事。这个想法是，这是一个人类权利，信息是一项人权，介于信息和能够使用该信息的人之间。我想我们当时其实是在谈论消防地图，以及最近南加州发生的火灾，还有发出的各种显示屏的局限性，
problems of typography, problems of the size of the type, sky-tried looking to see, even though she wasn't in our area, she was up in Portland, but she was looking to see where the old neighborhood, you know, where the fires were, and she couldn't. She wasn't able to access it. And I realized that I had come upon obstacles in trying to access that information, and she had come upon obstacles,
排版问题，字号大小问题。斯凯试着查看，尽管她不在我们这个地区，她在波特兰，但她想看看老街区在哪，你知道的，火灾在哪里，而她做不到。她无法获取这些信息。我意识到，我在试图获取该信息时遇到了障碍，而她也遇到了障碍，
trying to access that information. And she had come upon obstacles trying to access that information. And it really illuminated the fact that though they were different obstacles that the principal was the same, that bad design is committing the same moral sin as a lack of access for those with disabilities. In fact, really, at the end of the day, we all have disabilities. We all have cognitive limits. We all have limits of our senses. And a failure to recognize the multiplicity of barriers that stand between us and what sometimes is life-saving information is an urgent public work that needs to take place.
在试图获取该信息时遇到了障碍。这确实阐明了一个事实，即尽管它们是不同的障碍，但原则是相同的：糟糕的设计所犯下的道德罪过，与剥夺残疾人获取信息的权利是一样的。事实上，说到底，我们所有人其实都有残疾。我们所有人都有认知局限。我们所有人都有感官局限。而未能认识到在我们与有时能救命的信息之间存在的重重障碍的多样性，是一项亟待开展的紧迫公共工作。
The other aspect I should mention, where Skye is concerned, is that people with star guards disease, it's very interesting because I've run into others with star guards in my travels. If you ever see somebody with sunglasses on, maybe a dog, and a cane, and walking very fast. It may confuse you. You may wonder why is this blind person walking very fast? Well, as I've been studying visual cognition, one of the things that's come up is optic flow, and this notion of the way in which we perceive depth, not just by stereopsis, not just by combining the images in our two eyes, but also in the way
我要提到的另一个关于斯凯的方面是，患有斯塔加特病的人非常有趣，因为我在旅行中遇到过其他患有斯塔加特病的人。如果你看到有人戴着太阳镜，可能带着一只狗，拿着手杖，走得非常快。这可能会让你感到困惑。你可能会想，为什么这个盲人走得这么快？嗯，正如我一直在研究的视觉认知一样，出现的一个问题是光流，以及我们感知深度的方式这一概念，不仅仅是通过立体视觉，不仅仅是通过结合我们双眼中的图像，而且还通过
in which the entire visual field moves by as a different speeds, nearer things, you know, like when you're on the road, for example, and you notice that the telephone poles are going by faster in your field of vision than say a distant house or a distant mountain. That sort of thing. Or even just the furniture in your living room.
整个视野以不同速度掠过的方式，比如更近的东西，你知道的，就像你在路上时，你注意到电线杆在你视野中掠过的速度比远处的房子或远处的山要快。诸如此类的事情。甚至只是你客厅里的家具。
What you're doing is you're building a depth map of the whole visual field, the whole visual world, and you're doing it with motion parallax, rather than with stereopsis. And this helps give you a sense of where you are. Well, Skye's peripheral vision is fine. She sees the car coming around the corner. She just can't read because she's lost her
你在做的是建立整个视野、整个视觉世界的深度图，你是通过运动视差而不是立体视觉来做到的。这有助于让你对自己的位置有一个概念。嗯，斯凯的周边视力很好。她看到汽车拐弯。她只是无法阅读，因为她失去了
central vision, but the faster she moves, the faster she walks, the more complete the picture of the world that she lives in is. And so you'll see that. And a lot of people think that people with stargarts disease and other forms of macular degeneration, they think they're faking it. They think they're not blind at all. But no, they're just, they're seeing with a different part of the visual field. That's amazing. 99% invisible is Emmett Fitzgerald, who helped me a lot with this interview. Avery Trophiman, Sharif Yusuf, Taren Masa,
中央视力，但她动得越快，走得越快，她所生活的世界的画面就越完整。所以你会看到这一点。很多人认为患有斯塔加特病和其他形式黄斑变性的人是在装病。他们认为这些人根本没有失明。但不是，他们只是用视野的不同部分在看。这太棒了。《99% Invisible》的制作人员有埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，他在这次采访中帮了我很多，还有埃弗里·特罗菲曼、谢里夫·优素福、塔伦·马萨、
composer Sean Riel, senior producer Katie Mingle, senior editor Delaney Hall, digital director Kurt Colstad, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all podcasting.
作曲家肖恩·里尔、高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔、高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔、数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特ad，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的广播街制作。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇聚了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。
We are supported by our listeners, and that matters so much. Thanks. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI-ORG, where I Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But the real 99PI HQ is at 99PI dot org. HQ is at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们得到听众的支持，这非常重要。谢谢。你可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% Invisible 并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，@节目 99PI-ORG，我也玩 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit。但真正的 99PI 总部在 99PI dot org。总部在 99pi.org。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。